We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Do you mind if I talk to you while we walk? If you've ever seen an episode of the TV show The West Wing,
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。你介意我们边走边聊吗？如果你看过电视剧《白宫风云》的一集，
you probably know one of its trademark scenes. The walk and talk. You're going to this meeting? Yeah. WW160, you've been able to find it? I don't even know where I am right now. I'm looking on this side again. the walk and talk. The West Wing is filled with these. Two staffers, the White House walk through the halls, talking about some government policy or political plot point.
你可能知道它的标志性场景之一。边走边聊。你要去开会吗？是的。WW160，你找到了吗？我现在甚至不知道我在哪儿。我正在看这一边。边走边聊。《白宫风云》里充满了这样的场景。两名工作人员在白宫走廊里穿行，谈论着某种政府政策或政治情节要点。
The dialogue isn't necessarily exciting on its own, but add a little motion and you've got some compelling freaking television. Well, we may as well get used to having meetings in the quarters from now on. Maybe our only hope. And now know why they made the Oval Office a special shape. But after you watch a few episodes, you might notice something. The characters almost never look at each other. They mostly look straight ahead.
对话本身未必令人兴奋，但加上一点动作，你就得到了一些引人入胜的电视节目。好吧，我们最好习惯从现在开始在宿舍里开会。也许是我们唯一的希望。现在我知道他们为什么把椭圆形办公室设计成特殊的形状了。但看了几集之后，你可能会注意到一些事情。角色们几乎从不看对方。他们大多直视前方。
Do you mind if I talk to you while we walk? And there's a good reason for this. When people walk and talk, they don't need to look at each other. We use our eyes to navigate. We use our ears to listen. But that doesn't work if you're deaf. That's our reporter today, Tom Driesbach. He went to Gallaudet University in Washington, DC to talk to a researcher in Robert's Servage. Gallaudet is the only university in the world designed entirely for the deaf and hard of hearing. Robert is deaf himself, and he's been looking
你介意我们边走边聊吗？这背后有一个很好的理由。当人们边走边聊时，他们不需要看着对方。我们用眼睛导航。我们用耳朵倾听。但如果你是聋人，这就行不通了。这就是我们今天的记者，汤姆·德里斯巴赫。他去了华盛顿特区的加劳德特大学，与研究员罗伯特·瑟维奇交谈。加劳德特是世界上唯一一所完全为聋人和听障人士设计的大学。罗伯特本人也是聋人，他一直在研究
into this question of how deaf people walk inside. He told me about his latest experiment. So I'm doing a comparative study between people who are speaking, walking along H Street. I think that doesn't sound like a Robert. Yeah, that's actually the voice of Carolyn Restler. She's an interpreter at Gallaudet. Carry on that.
聋人如何在室内行走的问题。他告诉了我他最新的实验。所以我正在做一个比较研究，对象是沿着H街行走的人。我想那听起来不像罗伯特。是的，那实际上是卡罗琳·雷斯特勒的声音。她是加劳德特的口译员。继续。
So I'm doing a comparative study between people who are speaking, walking along H Street, and walking together and speaking to one another. So two hearing diets with the same kind of camera on their head, and then two deaf diets who have this camera mounted on their head. Diad is just a fancy term in sociology for a pair of people. So Robert put cameras on these two pairs of people, hearing and death, and he had them walk down the street.
所以我正在做一个比较研究，对象是沿着H街行走的人，以及边走边互相交谈的人。所以两对听力正常的人，头上戴着同样的摄像头，然后两对聋人，头上也安装了这种摄像头。Diad（二元组）只是社会学中指代一对人的一个花哨术语。所以罗伯特给这两对人（听力正常和聋人）戴上了摄像头，让他们沿着街道走。
And he did this so he could precisely monitor what people look at when they walk and talk, versus when they walk and sign. And he found very clear differences. To hearing people look straight ahead the whole time they were walking, you might see just a few seconds, very rare seconds, when the person would look at the other person who they were walking beside and speaking. They wouldn't ever make eye contact.
他这样做是为了精确监测人们在边走边聊时，与边走边打手语时所看的地方。他发现了非常明显的差异。听力正常的人在走路时一直直视前方，你可能只会看到几秒钟，非常罕见的几秒钟，当那个人会看向他身边一起走路并交谈的另一个人。他们从不进行眼神交流。
One would look at the other. Well, as with deaf people, there was a continuous maintained eye contact. So because American sign language is a visual language, it requires constant eye contact. But maintaining eye contact also means you can't pay full attention to any obstacles up ahead. And that's a problem if you're walking. I mean I guess if you can think about yourself as a person you can hear. If you weren't looking at the road as you were
一个人会看向另一个人。然而，对于聋人来说，有持续保持的眼神交流。因为美国手语是一种视觉语言，它需要持续的眼神交流。但保持眼神交流也意味着你无法完全注意前方可能出现的障碍物。如果你在走路，这就是个问题。我的意思是，我想如果你把自己想象成一个能听见的人。如果你在开车时没有看路，
driving and looking at your passenger, as you're driving down the road, you can imagine how difficult that might be to mediate your car down the road. Well the same kind of things happens with deaf people, but we watch out for one another. For walking and signing to work, the people holding a conversation need to keep an eye out for obstacles. But it's not like deaf people make a deal at the beginning of a conversation, you talk, I'll be the lookout. When deaf people are looking at one another, there's an agreement, an internal agreement, unspoken agreement that's understood between the two people conversing. It's almost like the people when you're in a conversation, you're in a kind of dance, where you're not discussing what's happening between each other,
而是在开车时看着你的乘客，你可以想象在路上驾驶汽车有多困难。嗯，聋人身上也发生了同样的事情，但我们会互相照看。为了让边走边打手语行得通，进行对话的人需要留意障碍物。但这并不是说聋人在对话开始时会达成协议，你说话，我来负责观察。当聋人互相注视时，有一种默契，一种内在的协议，一种在交谈的两人之间心照不宣的协议。这几乎就像人们在交谈时，处于一种舞蹈中，你们不是在讨论彼此之间正在发生什么，
but you just sort of know what the next move should be. That's exactly it. When you're dancing, you kind of work with your partner in the way they breathe, the way they move their body, and you respond accordingly, the same thing holds true with deaf people in a conversation. When they're designing buildings, most hearing architects are not thinking about providing a venue for this dance. Robert says a lot of spaces are too narrow and confining for a good conversation.
而是你只是某种程度上知道下一步该做什么。正是这样。当你跳舞时，你会根据舞伴的呼吸方式、身体移动方式与他们配合，并做出相应的反应，聋人在交谈时也是如此。在设计建筑物时，大多数听力正常的建筑师并没有考虑为这种舞蹈提供场地。罗伯特说，很多空间太狭窄和局促，无法进行良好的对话。
There's this sense that buildings were not designed in such a way as if they accommodate deaf people. So how does that feel? I guess the best way to say that is like we feel like sardines. You know, like we're all lined up one after the next and we're trying to converse in that way and there's no ease in our communication. It's actually also true of many buildings
有一种感觉是，建筑的设计并没有考虑到聋人的需求。那感觉如何？我想最好的说法是，我们感觉像沙丁鱼。你知道，就像我们一个接一个地排成一排，试图以那种方式交谈，而我们的交流并不轻松。这实际上也适用于许多建筑物，
at Gallaudet University, even though it's dedicated to teaching the deaf and hard of hearing. It's a relatively old campus. A lot of buildings were built in the mid 1800s and it looks like a typical northeastern liberal arts college. But there are signs that this school is different than your Wesleyans and your Amhersts or whatever. Take for example the doorbells on campus.
在加劳德特大学，尽管它致力于教授聋人和听障人士。这是一个相对古老的校园。许多建筑建于19世纪中期，看起来像典型的东北部文理学院。但有迹象表明，这所学校与你的卫斯理大学、阿默斯特学院或其他学校不同。以校园里的门铃为例。
Nowadays people use lights, you can flick a light switch and let somebody know that you're at the door, but in the 1800s before electric light they used vibration. The university has a display of an old doorbell. It's about four feet high with a round metal handle attached to a chain. And at the other end of that chain is a lead weight. You'd arrive at the door and you'd simply pull the chain. With that hit to the floor, I mean we're listening to the chain, but that hit to the floor, you'd immediately get it, someone's at the door.
如今人们使用灯光，你可以拨动电灯开关让某人知道你在门口，但在1800年代电灯出现之前，他们使用振动。大学里有一个旧门铃的展示。它大约四英尺高，有一个连接在链条上的圆形金属把手。链条的另一端是一个铅坠。你到达门口，只需拉动链条。随着那东西撞击地板，我的意思是我们在听链条的声音，但那撞击地板的声音，你会立刻明白，有人在门口。
That's Hansel Bauman. He is now the director of design and planning a Gallaudet. Bauman is not deaf, and in this case that is his voice. And this was one of the really cool, but kind of a necronomistic innovations at Gallaudet. But several years ago, the university realized that some of its standards of architecture and innovation had slipped. So they asked Hansel to help lead a group project that would rethink the campus design with deaf people in mind. They called the project Deaf Space. Deaf Space really started at the beginning of time whenever there are deaf people there is
那是汉塞尔·鲍曼。他现在是加劳德特设计与规划的主任。鲍曼不是聋人，在这种情况下，那是他的声音。这是加劳德特非常酷但有点时代错乱的创新之一。但几年前，大学意识到其建筑和创新的一些标准已经下滑。所以他们请汉塞尔领导一个小组项目，重新思考以聋人为核心的校园设计。他们把这个项目称为“聋人空间”。聋人空间实际上从时间之初就开始了，无论哪里有聋人，就有
this idea of Deaf Space. Deaf people have sensibilities of adapting their world to their way of being. The campus took those ideas and poured them into the design of a new building called the Sorenson Language and Communication Center, but everyone calls it the SLCC. It was built in 2008, and they're also working on a new dorm. Hansel Bauman showed me around, and I saw that there are a lot of little innovations. Some that come to mind immediately like the type of doors.
这种“聋人空间”的理念。聋人有将世界适应他们生存方式的敏感性。校园采用了这些想法，并将其融入到一座名为索伦森语言与交流中心的新建筑设计中，但每个人都称它为SLCC。它建于2008年，他们也在筹建一个新的宿舍。汉塞尔·鲍曼带我参观了一圈，我看到有很多小创新。有些立刻浮现在脑海中，比如门的类型。
If you're walking and signing a normal door will stop your conversation cold. You notice we just passed through two sliding doors. The sliding doors are purposely designed to allow people to continue, assign the conversation as they enter the building so you don't stop, open the door, start the conversation again. And then there are more subtle changes. One of the big ideas behind Deaf Space is avoiding eye strain. That's because when you communicate all day with your eyes, it's easy to get tired. So if you have bad lighting conditions, for example,
如果你在走路并打手语，一扇普通的门会立刻中断你的谈话。你注意到我们刚刚穿过了两扇感应门。感应门是专门设计的，允许人们在进入建筑物时继续打手语对话，这样你就不用停下来、开门、然后再开始对话。还有一些更微妙的变化。“聋人空间”背后的一个大理念是避免眼睛疲劳。这是因为当你整天用眼睛交流时，很容易感到疲倦。所以如果你有糟糕的照明条件，例如，
which is backlighting, glare, high contrast between dark spaces and light spaces, there are conditions in the environment which tend to visually vibrate. Like if you have horizontal blinds and light coming through the blinds, you'll start getting vibration. All of those annoyances in and of themselves may not be so bad, but taken together
也就是背光、眩光、黑暗空间和明亮空间之间的高对比度，环境中存在往往会产生视觉振动的条件。比如如果你有百叶窗，光线透过百叶窗射入，你就会开始感到振动。所有这些烦恼本身可能并不算太糟，但加在一起，
over the time of the day, it's the beginning of eye strain. And eye strain really wears people out, basically. I've actually noticed that myself, like when I look at horizontal blinds and get that sort of eye vibration, and I thought I was just weird. I don't think you're weird, Tom. So the Sorenson building avoids those traps.
在一天的时间里，这就是眼睛疲劳的开始。眼睛疲劳基本上会让人精疲力竭。我实际上自己也注意到了，比如当我看着百叶窗并产生那种眼睛振动时，我以为我只是很奇怪。我不认为你很奇怪，汤姆。所以索伦森大楼避免了这些陷阱。
It has enormous windows and a lot of diffuse light to reduce shadows. While you have some direct light coming in, it's still kind of filled with this diffuse quality of light that there's really not a lot of shadows on the face. There's not a lot of distraction on surfaces behind us. And when we walked by a classroom, Hansel pointed inside at the color scheme. The color of the blue classroom, that's a color we've been experimenting with, is a good contrast to a range of skin tones. You can just so clearly see sign language in there, and that would be better when you say you can the next door.
它有巨大的窗户和大量的漫射光来减少阴影。虽然有一些直射光射入，但它仍然充满了这种漫射光质量，脸上真的没有太多阴影。我们身后的表面也没有太多干扰。当我们走过一间教室时，汉塞尔指着里面的配色方案。蓝色教室的颜色，那是我们一直在试验的颜色，与各种肤色形成了很好的对比。你可以非常清楚地看到那里的手语，当你提到隔壁时，那会更好。
Not all of the changes worked. In the building's design they decided to round off sharp corners. That's because if you can't hear footsteps from around the corner, a lot of times you won't know someone's coming at all and people bump into each other. So they rounded off these corners. Again, a lesson learned. We realized that people now hug that curved corner like a race car and you still kind of have that problem.
并非所有的改变都奏效。在建筑设计中，他们决定将尖角磨圆。这是因为如果你听不到拐角处的脚步声，很多时候你根本不知道有人要过来，人们会撞在一起。所以他们把这些拐角磨圆了。同样，这是一个教训。我们意识到人们现在像赛车一样贴着那个弯曲的拐角走，你仍然会遇到那种问题。
So our strategy now is to create glass corners that allow you to kind of see through the corner, but it still extend that period of time that you have before you get to the corner. The building is definitely pleasant to look at. The color scheme is nice, the lightest pleasing, but as someone who can hear, I probably would not have noticed a lot of these little changes if Hansel hadn't pointed them out. But after walking around with Hansel, the most striking thing about the building
所以我们现在的策略是创造玻璃拐角，让你能够透过拐角看，但这仍然延长了你在到达拐角之前的时间。这座建筑看起来确实令人愉悦。配色方案很好，光线令人满意，但作为一个能听见的人，如果汉塞尔没有指出，我可能不会注意到很多这些小变化。但在与汉塞尔走了一圈后，关于这座建筑最引人注目的事情
was the level of thoughtfulness. Everything in the building seems to have a specific thought behind it. Chairs are on wheels so you can constantly rearrange them in circles, and they made benches out of wood because you can feel vibrations more easily through the wood. And they try to strategically place air conditioning units so they don't make as much noise. That's because it turns out that hearing aids can pick up that sound in a really jarring way.
是那种体贴的程度。建筑里的每件事似乎都有特定的想法。椅子装有轮子，这样你可以不断地把它们重新排列成圆圈，他们用木头制作长椅，因为你可以更容易地通过木头感觉到振动。他们试图战略性地放置空调装置，这样它们就不会发出太大的噪音。这是因为事实证明，助听器会以一种非常刺耳的方式接收到那种声音。
And for Hansel, working on deaf space has meant becoming sensitive to a range of issues that he had never thought of before. I think the window that the deaf experience offers to architects is to provide us with a new kind of awareness around what's working and what's not working in a room. That we might accept every day is just kind of our condition and we're not aware of it. It's not in front of us in a way that we can name what's the
对于汉塞尔来说，从事“聋人空间”的工作意味着要对一系列他以前从未想过的议题变得敏感。我认为聋人体验为建筑师提供的窗口是，让我们对房间里什么有效、什么无效有了新的认识。我们可能每天都接受它作为我们的某种状况，而我们并没有意识到它。它不是以一种我们可以命名的方式出现在我们面前，
aggregation in the room or the environmental stressor. We don't have a way to recognize that, whereas I think it's part of every day deaf experience. That's why everyone involved in the deaf space Project says it is not just for Deaf people. Fundamentally, this is about universal design. Designed for the widest range of people possible with a variety of abilities, because not only is it more inclusive, it's demonstrably better design, regardless of need. When AXO and Smart Design collaborated on making a potato peeler for people with arthritis, they created a new peeler with an ergonomic, big, fat black handle that turned out to be better for everyone. Now you see that application everywhere.
房间里的聚集或环境压力源。我们没有办法识别这一点，而我认为这是聋人日常体验的一部分。这就是为什么参与“聋人空间”项目的每个人都说它不仅仅是为了聋人。从根本上说，这是关于通用设计。为具有各种能力的最广泛的人群进行设计，因为这不仅更具包容性，而且无论需求如何，它都是明显更好的设计。当AXO和Smart Design合作制造一种为关节炎患者使用的削皮器时，他们创造了一种带有符合人体工程学的、大而肥厚的黑色手柄的新削皮器，结果证明这对每个人都更好。现在你到处都能看到这种应用。
Designing for the deaf may be more subtle, but if we mitigate eye strain and hearing aid interference from American listeners, there's no telling how much better everyone's life would be. how much better everyone's life would be. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Tom Drys Bach with a little help from me Roman Mars. We are a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. The show is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange, making public radio more public, more at PRX.org. Sam Greenspan is our charm city producer at large.
为聋人设计可能更微妙，但如果我们减轻美国听众的眼睛疲劳和助听器干扰，无法预知每个人的生活会变得多好。每个人的生活会变得多好。《99%隐形》本周由汤姆·德里斯巴赫制作，我罗曼·马斯提供了一点帮助。我们是旧金山KALW 91.7本地公共广播电台和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。该节目由PRX（公共广播交易所）发行，使公共广播更加公共，更多信息请访问PRX.org。萨姆·格林斯潘是我们魅力之城的特约制作人。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but you can always just catch up with us on the website. It's 99%invisible.org. or. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞该节目。我在Twitter上是@RomanMars，但你总是可以在网站上跟上我们的进度。网址是99%invisible.org。或者。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。